he's very different than me it just
seems impossible that is Sally Field and
her new cookie comedy was just hit
theaters today hello my name is Doris of
making her an early oscars frontrunner
by the way now she won her first Oscar
36 years ago for normal ray and now
she's gonna be 70 in November so on this
flashback friday i took sally back
through her legendary career
but almost five and a half decades of
working in this business and we just
want to highlight some of the glare Ruby
33 years and starting in the 60s with
Gidget which was many ways you're
launching pad into Hollywood not in many
ways and everywhere that was my
beginning yes oh man as if women can't
get along perfectly well without you and
then on to the 70s smokey nabam yes I
was one of them you know certainly more
importantly even before smokey is that
they done something called civil I don't
find happiness anywhere and that I had
done right before I mean literally just
wrapped civil and before it was ever on
the air I was like sort of a
miraculously hired to to be in smoking
bandit and we just sort of did that by
the seat of our pants think of it as a
wedding Posse and stretching a bride
I don't think anybody thought that that
was going to be that kind of classic it
turned out to be who knew and then it
was a bit of a you know again a bit sort
of jumping up and down in place until
something else came its way my way which
was Norma Norma was Norma Rae Sally
Field won her first Oscar for the role
an ET interview after that win I just
wanted to show you your first
Entertainment Tonight interview just
with what you said about the Oscar win
and 1981 what did I say you kind of have
the feeling well I'm coming back with
Oscar number two and then number three
I'm gonna win 8 the role you just want
to break every record that ever was god
that's a very smart young man smart and
prolific Sally's had more hits than we
have time to name mrs. Doubtfire Oh God
the whole time middle fold I knew it Oh
time steel magnolias I want to know how
that baby will ever know how wonderful
his mother was and Lincoln don't convene
another subcommittee to investigate me
sad teasin smile send it away field who
turned 70 this year plays an eccentric
older woman infatuated with the younger
man in her latest role in hello my name
is Doris I'm so sorry did that on
purpose didn't know yeah Doris Doris he
are you okay yeah and here's the thing
about Sally Field she makes it look so
easy but she told me well it's not to
have a long-term career you have to
buckle up and you have to be willing to
head down stream as you know on a roller
coaster shooting to the ground as well
as one that's shooting to the sky you
have to be able to ride it
you